[Musique]
qu'allez vous leur faites vous là on
3315 l'angleterre enfin les bailleurs je
suis parti parce que il y avait le
contrat donc c'était une âme un prétexte
qu'il y avait aussi peut-être j'en avais
marre je leur ai demandé de changer un
peu d'air on serait bien là et bien tu
as un moment de changer d'air de partir
voir j'aime échanger en partant on peut
regarder comment on était avant les bars
et des choses ses qualités ses manies
des pro bass et concernant l'avenir
j'imagine qu'à paris facilement s'est
regardés par les gens venaient de deux
enfants d'amis dont un de ses six
dernières on voit ça aussi il y avait
une certaine époque à une certaine
pression qui était un peu un journal est
mort un peu de m pas vraiment à cette
belle connerie ça fait prétentieux de
dire qu'on en a marre du succès mais
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des mères dont
elle a besoin qu'on fait du recul des
gens ont l'impression que tous leurs
papiers la télévision mme royal est dans
les premiers temps j'ai un manager
j'allais pas vécu ça depuis longtemps
que personne ne connaissait avant vous
aviez un argot là bas il n'a pas eu le
monde dont sentir à cette journée allait
produire un disque à londres ça veut
dire demander à des gens de m'aider à
trouver le bon son pour les émissions
s'ils ne comprennent pas le français
s'il s'adresse pas à faire les ford
de comprendre le français voulait parler
il ya une grosse différence entre eux
vous pouvez pas bosser ensemble sauf le
camp suis arrivé à l'ombre ce concept
que étant français je devais défendre
l'image de la france et c'est un blog en
rouge
et puis ça fait trois ans maintenant que
j'habite là bas pour pour que ta vie
devient agréable là bas il faut petit
ennui admise un petit peu pour ça que
bon on peut avoir des rêves sur
l'angleterre parce que l'on a acheté le
mois beaucoup de disques anglet moi
quand j'étais parmi les je vais aller
vers 12h00 des mecs bien dire moi je
pense que maintenant l'angleterre déjà
leur martèle 50 et autant de bauchi que
les baroin il ya autant de il ya autant
de business sinon plus c'est vraiment
les considère vraiment comme un produit
vraiment dur de garder ton identité
[Musique]